[Música]
imagine que você tenha morado muito
tempo sozinho num pequeno apartamento e
por que você sempre morou sozinho você
adquiriu práticas que têm a ver com a
tua comodidade com o teu prazer
facilidade na hora de organizar a vida
mas aí por alguma razão alguém vai morar
com você você vai compartilhar aquele
mesmo espaço com alguém e rapidamente
você percebe que algumas coisas que você
fazia você pode continuar fazendo elas
não atrapalham em nada a tua convivência
mas outras coisas se você continuar
fazendo você vai entristecê aquele que
convive com você como partimos da
premissa de que toda convivência nem que
dá chance igual de felicidade àqueles
que convivem você não poderá mais fazer
exatamente como você fazia quando morava
sozinho
chamamos de ética a diferença entre o
que você faria se estivesse sozinho no
mundo eo que você faz porque tem alguém
do seu lado que tem tanto direito de uma
convivência feliz quanto você
pois muito bem eu imagino que você
perceba não é uma tabela pronta que
aquelas duas pessoas vão ler mas é uma
interação permanente identificando o que
querem para aquela convivência e o que
não é possível aceitar lhe dentro
aqueles dois
o de não precisar disso cego de repouso
e de silêncio que passa a ser para eles
o maior valor de convivência mas aqueles
dois podem precisar de divertimento de
agito e de intensidade e poças e é esse
também o maior valor para a convivência
caberá a ele se identificar o que é
fundamental pra eles a ética é a
identificação dos valores fundamentais
para que aqueles dois possam ter chances
iguais de felicidade e possam viver de
maneira feliz naquela convivência
daquele espaço
isso vale para aquelas duas pessoas vale
para cinco pessoas de uma família 50
pessoas numa sala de aula 50 mil pessoas
numa pequena cidade 200 milhões de
pessoas no país
o toda a humanidade a ética é a arte da
convivência eo respeito às chances
iguais de felicidade para todos aqueles
que interagem não tem tabela pronta e os
valores são contraditórios você sabe que
a transparência é fundamental para a
convivência a transparência é um baita
valor de convivência e graças a
transparência a gente diminui a
maracutaia diminui a mentira diminui o
cinismo a hipocrisia a a desigualdade e
então a transparência ela nos importa
mas o sigilo e à confidencialidade que
são o contrário da transparência também
são fundamentais para nossa convivência
sem a confidencialidade o sacerdote não
confessa o contador não contabiliza o
auditor não auditada o professor não
aplica prova o concurso público não se
realiza o psicanalista não analisa o
juiz não julga então perceba se a
transparência é fundamental o sigilo que
é o seu contrário também é a ética é a
identificação naquele espaço que é o
nosso de interação daquilo que mais
importa para nós por isso
é muito mais do que uma tabela pronta
que divide respeitadores e não
respeitadores somos todos convidados
para que haja uma formação ética mais
importante a refletir de maneira lúcida
sobre o tipo de sociedade que queremos
para nós se queremos uma sociedade e
silenciosa onde o repouso é o maior
valor
se queremos uma sociedade vibrante onde
a intensidade o maior valor e aí é claro
e identificando o que é fundamental para
nós saberemos diagnosticar os
comportamentos que não podemos tolerar
comportamentos canalhas e indevidos
comportamentos que buscam trazer
vantagem para quem age mas destroem a
convivência destroem os valores
garantidores de felicidade para todos a
ética é a vitória da convivência sobre a
análise mas como teremos que pensar como
teremos que identificar o que mais conta
para nós é claro que haverá angústia
haverá dúvida sobre o que é mais valioso
que é mais importante e portanto toda a
vida ética inseparável do medo do
arrependimento do medo de não ter
pensado direito do medo de não ter
contribuído para a construção da
sociedade mais justa a angústia nos
acompanhará quanto maior for a lucidez
que tivermos mais percebemos o quanto é
difícil saber o que queremos para nós
aí eu estava falando isso na minha linha
é nunca dei aula para o auditório tão
grande mas lá na universidade os
auditórios eram grandes e uma jovem
levantou a mão uma jovem de capital
estético elevadíssimo topografia e
lucent uma jovem incrível ela levantou a
mão e falou nossa professora obrigado
pelo conceito de angústia eu sempre fui
angustiada eu nunca soube identificar
com clareza os limites da minha ação e o
que eu quero para a minha vida eu sempre
tive dúvidas
então obrigado eu aprendi hoje que eu
sou super angustiada e agora eu sei até
a palavra que o meu sentimento é
sempre me acompanhou aí eu peguei e
falei nossa é uma jovem tão linda é aqui
na universidade tinha tudo para ter uma
visão mais ingênua da vida você não quer
me dar um exemplo da tua angústia
aí ela falou professor o meu namorado
estuda aqui na frente eu faço jornalismo
ele estuda na pole ele faz mecatrônica
senhor pode imaginar o tipinho mas eu
gosto dele
nossa a gente namora faz tempo o
professor e agora em junho tem corpus
christi a semana do saco cheio nós da
comunicação fazemos jucá jogos
universitários de comunicação esse ano
foi em guaxupé e eu falei com o meu
namorado vem comigo vamos brincar vamos
divertir
vamos aproveitar que não tem aula ele
não pôde professora que estava
terminando um robô
ela falou faltavam só duas antenas assim
por roubo ficar pronto vai você ele
falou o professor quando eu cheguei em
guaxupé
percebi que o esporte é um pretexto
muito sem vergonha daquele encontro não
diga o que as pessoas estão fazendo
sacanagem professora é meu que é moça
sacanagem ela falou sexo professor nós e
lamentei muito nunca ter sido convidado
principal de juca deve ser um espetáculo
e aí então ela falou professor assim que
eu desci do ônibus um rapaz de sunga só
de sunga os cultura saliente muito
diferente do meu mirrado mecatrônico não
perguntou nem meu nome já me propõe na
lata uma cópula furtiva uma bêbada
mágica garantia desaparecer magicamente
após o coito e foi aí que eu lembrei do
senhor quem falei não entendia onde é
que você entrei na história ela falou o
professor é o seguinte não é o senhor
que fala que os valores são
contraditórios são complexos a ética ea
identificação do mais fundamental para
nós a incerteza paira ea gente angustia
sou eu que falo então professor na hora
de decidir dar ou não dar lembrei do
senhor
nossa o que queremos para nós a moça tem
razão dar ou não dar é um problema
absolutamente relevante para nós
eu estive dando uma palestra para a
maior empresa de tecnologia do mundo e o
primeiro valor do pam ner era o
divertimento era nos estados unidos e o
primeiro valor estava escrito lá tu ra
fã divertimento significa ali é preciso
se divertir quem não se diverte ali
atrapalha convivência quem não se
diverte ali a atrapalha a obtenção
daquilo que todo mundo está querendo
buscar ali divertir é fundamental que
essa moça fosse é tomar a decisão dela
entre dar em não dar pelo banner da
empresa de tecnologia ela já estaria
andando atrás de uma moita para um
marombado de sunga
porém como eu disse a ética é sempre um
cobertor curto
os valores são contraditórios então
cobertor curto porque aquecer a canela
importante é o valor a que seu ouvido é
importante é o valor mas o cobertor é
curto e teremos que ver que valor vale
mais entre a canela quente o ouvido
quente
assim também o divertimento é o valor
mas não é o único valor a pautar as
nossas vidas e eu queria falar de um
valor que pra mim é particularmente
ausente na nossa sociedade que é a
fidelidade
se você sair na rua e perguntar para as
pessoas o que é fidelidade elas dirão
fidelidade ao namorado fidelidade ao
amigo fidelidade à empresa mas pra nós
fidelidade é sempre assim mesmo
fidelidade é sempre assim mesmo é uma
coerência entre a tua prática de agora a
tua decisão de agora e os discursos de
ontem as promessas de ontem os acertos
os entendimentos de ontem a fidelidade é
um alinhamento entre o que você prometeu
ontem e o que você decide fazer hoje a
fidelidade portanto costura a
imediatidade do presente com as
promessas do passado por isso a
fidelidade
confere integridade a tua trajetória
integridade mesmo de integral de íntegro
você respeita o próprio passado
respeitando as suas propostas
as tuas sugestões às cláusulas morais
que você afirma respeitar e aí então
sendo assim a fidelidade
você poderia levantar a mão e perguntou
à professora porque alguém agiria de
maneira infiel porque alguém desmentiria
o próprio passado é simples
entre o momento que você propôs hoje o
momento que você age acontecem coisas e
se você se meter a respeitar o que você
prometeu você poderá perder a moça
perderá uma lombada de sunga mas no
lugar do marombar do que se julga
você pode colocar uma eleição a vitória
em uma eleição você pode botar uma
grande venda e é muito difícil abrir mão
é muito difícil respeitar o que você
prometeu porque surgiram coisas novas
que tornam o respeito ao prometido uma
perda a perda de um ganho de um lucro de
uma vantagem de uma vitória parlamentar
então é muito difícil às vezes você
respeitar aquilo que você mesmo prometeu
neste momento você levanta a mão e diz
professor porque algum idiota
respeitaria o que prometeu
abrindo mão de tantas coisas são
fundamentais então vai aqui o meu
comentário é que quando você fez as suas
promessas
tinha alguém te ouvindo sabe quando você
diz que vai fazer alguma coisa
é possível que tenha alguém que acredite
em você e esse alguém tem por você
confiança certeza que no futuro você
respeitará o que está dizendo
e por que você prometeu e essa pessoa
confia em você
essa pessoa ela construiu agendas criou
expectativas fez investimentos mudou
trajetórias de vida criou os sonhos tudo
em função da tua promessa e da confiança
que ela tinha
em que você seria fiel ao que estava
prometendo assim se você resolver mudar
de idéia
para poder levar uma vantagem você
deixar essas pessoas no limbo você
deixar essas pessoas a ver navios
é você levar a essas pessoas a
desconfiança eo que é pior não só
desconfiar de você mas passaram a
desconfiar de todos passaram a
desconfiar de toda a sociedade passaram
a acreditar que na verdade não vale a
pena admitir que alguém possa ser fiel e
aí então haverá uma espécie de
desconfiança generalizada onde a palavra
de ninguém vale nada é mais ou menos
esse tipo de sociedade que nas últimas
décadas temos construído para nós uma
sociedade onde a palavra dada e objeto
de chacota de riso
somos absolutamente fiscalizados por
câmeras radares quebras molas
tornozeleiras e tudo aquilo que
desmoraliza a vida
por essas e por outras você poderá
escolher entre continuar contando com a
confiança das pessoas contribuindo assim
para uma sociedade onde as pessoas ainda
ainda podem dizer coisas e as outras
podem ainda acreditar no que é dito ou
então você pode fazer parte de uma
espécie de bandalheira generalizada
aonde o que é dito nunca valeu nada e
aonde só a verificação é é garantidora
de alguma certeza
por essas e por outras eu espero que
você entenda que a fidelidade é a
integridade da tua trajetória que
desperta confiança em você e se você já
ouviu falar em sustentabilidade
você deve imaginar que sustentabilidade
é um valor da vida de agora que projeta
um futuro legal de vivendi conviver a
sustentabilidade recomenda você não
jogar destruindo o jogo não vencerem
viabilizando a vitória de amanhã não
lucrar inviabilizando o lucro de amanhã
não tem um trio viabilizando o triunfo
de amanhã
por essas e por outras
a sustentabilidade limita atua com a tua
conduta hoje para que você possa
continuar vivendo feliz
amanhã a sustentabilidade que é um
respeito ao futuro depende da fidelidade
ao passado
de repende da fidelidade e da confiança
que a fidelidade pode trazer
quando você abre mão de ganhos e
vantagens para não deixar ninguém na mão
para que possam continuar acreditando
para que possa continuar valendo a pena
interagir ouvindo as pessoas e levando a
sério o que elas dizem e nesse momento
você poderá perceber que você está numa
sinuca de bico entre levar aquela
vantagem imediata e de circunstância ou
então abrir mão de uma vantagem assumir
a perda em nome da integridade da
confiança da fidelidade e da
sustentabilidade e neste momento que
você faz esse cálculo
você poderia perguntar professor mas
entre ganhar agora e abrir mão do ganho
para respeitar o mundo que mim que me
que me cercam a é como é que eu faço
para decidir então vai aqui é a última
resposta da minha fala o que queremos
com a ética é a possibilidade de uma
vida feliz para todos
o que queremos com a ética é que todos
aqui tenhamos a mesma chance de um pouco
de felicidade na hora de interagir
portanto você faça os seus cálculos e se
eu vim até aqui a única meta era
proporcionar a você o que de melhor uma
pessoa pode proporcionar
a outra pessoa um mísero segundo de vida
que queiramos compartilhar de novo um
mísero segundo de vida feliz se fizermos
todos isso construiremos uma sociedade
mais justa mais fraterna e mais digna e
deixar para os nossos filhos
muitíssimo obrigado e até a próxima se
deus quiser
obrigado obrigado obrigado
[Aplausos]